quem é empreendedor
levanta a mão por favor quem aqui desejo
é ser empreendedor
quem aqui tem medo de empreender tenham
medo porque exatamente esse tipo de
coisa enfim eu sou empreendedor tem 15
anos
morro de medo de empreender assim como
movimentar nesse palco que mora medo da
vida é falar em público a sorte que a
gente vai ter um monte de toque hoje
inclusive tirando esse medo mas o meu
medo realmentes mas empreender é isso
medo todo santo dia mas a vontade de
chegar e além nclusive está aqui
levantando bandeiras assim é isso que a
gente faz é tentar superar essas
barreiras todo de empreender de fato é
isso que sabe estar de fato vulnerável
saber disso de aceitar esse medo para
conseguir passar pra frente quando me
chamaram pra fazer esse top que eu
fiquei extremamente feliz é óbvio é
principalmente com esse tema de quebra
cabeça certa forma a gente é considerado
como falou o agente pessoal da empresa é
considerado o quebrador de cabeça
profissional a gente se organiza e
organiza empresas é pra isso que a gente
é chamado e o que a gente faz no final
de tudo é pensar de forma diferente dar
outras soluções
quando a gente pensa de forma diferente
na verdade dá pra ficar bonito né pra
ficar só vendável é pra você com que o
outro sinta sinta uma idéia
sinto um produto/serviço sinto um evento
sinta qualquer coisa para fazer que
outros impactos de fato isso num momento
desse
ao escolher o que eu falaria pra cá eu
não queria trazer uma palestra não
queria trazer alguma coisa já pronta eu
queria trazer algo que conectar se com
essa cidade com vocês
enfim e trazer algo real eu fiquei
pensando bom tempo que seria que a gente
já fez projetos aqui mas mais do que
isso é o que eu sentir bem vindo
é teve uma vez que eu fui dar uma
palestra em curitiba
eu peguei um ônibus de floripa até
joinville e aqui eu peguei carona com um
amigo meu para curitiba e eu tive a
grata felicidade de sentar do lado de
uma pessoa que não estava entendendo a
mexer no celular de uma forma frenética
se importava em que eu falava e fazia
isso até eu cheguei perguntei para ela a
cara que é e era cega total desde os
dois anos de idade e ela me mostrou um
outro mundo mas ainda quando eu estava
me falou como é que era acessibilidade
como ela se orientava como ela fazia
para resolver os problemas dela como
todo mundo enfim aquilo foi se abriu
para mim uma nova uma nova visão para
ver do outro lado comecei a sentir uma
outra forma o nome perguntou alex que
você faz
eu falei para o trabalho com marcas e
ela falou o que é uma marca nunca em
nenhum momento alguém falou isso pra mim
tem uma marca nunca viu de fato eu tirei
um computador de bolso e pedi pra ela
posso gravar isso o pote e fluminense
ele saiu vencendo exatamente uma maçã
mordida em um mês longe então essa marca
aqui e aqui está em querer mas ela fica
estampada em todos os produtos
a gente já conhece ela principalmente
assim bonita sim sim
é é é primeiro né
que bonito esse pc olha que lindo de
fato essa frase onde uma pessoa ali
vendo a beleza com o dedo e olha como é
que isso transporta por uma outra
sensação pelo dedo ela vê beleza e no
final de tudo o que a gente tenta fazer
de fato esse que quebrar a cabeça é
tentar transportar não necessariamente
só estética mas a sensação para um outro
nível
a gente fala é empreendedorismo também é
isso entregar valor naquele momento
aliás técnica pra mim visual é não podia
ser um valor para ela é de uma outra
forma como ela percebe valor ia sempre
isso como é que o outro percebe o valor
aqui vem o que de valor pra mim é
e essa minha forma de tentar contribuir
de alguma jogada de alguma maneira para
cá trazendo um pouco de verdade pra mim
independente eu tenho três empresas há
15 anos já trabalhando com isso é o que
tem de mais rico em qualquer coisa que
eu já tenha feito em qualquer coisa que
eu já tenha empreendido são esses cinco
valores aqui é disso que quero falar com
vocês
o primeiro valor que eu trago sangue no
olho não só de contratação mas todo e
qualquer projeto que a gente faz isso
aqui é o primeiro você tem um limite que
era gente vai de fato e além disso fazer
as coisas muito loucas como por exemplo
o para enfim isso aqui é um
empreendimento imobiliário chamar a
gente para vender aquele empreendimento
caro a gente não vai fazer isso a gente
vai fazer uma experiência aqui dentro a
gente chegou e fez uma uma micro
campanha chamando casais do brasil
inteiro para passar três dias aqui uma
lua de mel numa situação assim e quem é
que vai querer fazer isso ninguém em uma
semana vem 600 casais querendo passar
três dias aqui uma lua de mel que a
gente queria
a gente queria proporcionar uma
experiência inclusive com o apartamento
não pronto e era isso que a gente
mostrava a promessa é essa
vai ser ruim galera não venham 600 maluf
falou para a gente e aí ea gente começou
a melhorar mais e a experiência foi
melhorando mas só que a gente apresentou
foi uma pessoa
um ano depois foi ficando legal foi
ficando bacana e olha só já prega no
chão de uma série de coisas poderiam dar
errado sim no olho vamos fazer isso
daqui dá certo a gente gerenciava toda
ansiedade toda experiência darem passos
em pontos sabendo que cada ponto e
melhorar o momento de se a gente queria
chegar de fato do que o outro sente esse
casal que falou no último dia lhe tal
falou-se próximo morador daqui 110%
sentiu esses três dias
aí o cara vai ser feliz a família vai
ser feliz pra caramba não mais do que
falar aquele metro quadrado ali custa
tanto como ver vão mostrar como é que
aquilo pode ser sentido de uma outra
forma
não adianta nada sangue no olho sem
outro lado eles andam muito juntos sem
propósito do coração fazer por fazer uma
coisa passar o rolo compressor não
adianta eu precisa disso
dá pra fazer de uma outra forma um
exemplo disso é um filme uma empresa
gigantesca empresa de energia mundial é
multinacional está falou alex apresenta
pra gente um negócio implicaria não como
vê o que vocês fizeram real que mudou a
vida de pessoas vão mostrar isso a gente
achou no interior do maranhão seis
comunidades quilombolas que a gente foi
lá e viu o valor dos carros a cultura
dos carros que eles tinham para passar
não era botar fio torre nada disso
como fazer com que eles contem a
história a gente criou esse documentário
para a empresa foi de graça olha só que
doida de graça
o documentário ganhou alguns prêmios
pelo mundo e tal rodou mas o mais
importante é a principal ferramenta
daquelas comunidades de acesso à terra e
direito à redução de imposto que eles
tinham eles usaram isso como ferramenta
para ele olha que legal é a importância
da empresa fazendo de uma outra forma
dá pra mudar isso o botão uma cidade no
guinness book uma são teoricamente banal
que recolher o óleo de cozinha
sabe a gente juntou um monte de escola
uma meta inicialmente audaciosa a gente
quase duplicou a meta em um mês pra quê
como game ficar isso mais do que botar
óleo vamos fazer parte de algo maior
dá pra ir além dá pra fazer o algo
interessante também sem vencer só faça
recolha enfim terceiro é valor que a
gente tem busca pelo novo todo o
trabalho que a gente começa a gente
começa do zero independente de qual
setor de qualquer agente começa do zero
a gente já contratou e trabalhou com
gente é garota de programa médico é
palhaço assistente social enfim pessoas
que sabem muito mais daquele assunto que
a gente a gente traz pra perto
exatamente o que a gente sempre começa
do zero e sempre vai aprendendo em cima
disso um objetivo um objetivo não uma
dica que eu dou a gente pesquisa muita
tendência também se esses dois tipos de
transformação qualquer empreendedorismo
ou ou vários empreendedores já estão
falando sobre transformação digital é o
que vai acontecer máquina enfim mas tem
um outro lado também lado de extrema
importância a transformação digital
outro que ainda não está sendo falado de
transformação criativa e com isso a
gente tem algumas coisas que eu chamo
dos sete deles enfim data vai mudar e
vai mudar muito a forma de como
informação é é como é que é absorvida
pelas empresas é direcionado dá em cima
disso
outro blog cheney a forma como
certificação transação financeiras a
transação de de documentos vão passar de
outra forma beleza transformação digital
vai acontecer já está acontecendo mas
não se esquecendo muito transformação
criativa que o outro lado é o lado
humano do coração ele também que
direciona muito negócio grande mas não
um brinde na estética band na promessa
de valor na promessa e na entrega o
assunto aqui a quebra cabeça grande pra
gente é isso um grande quebra-cabeça de
cada pecinha é um ponto de contato que a
gente conversa com o outro lado de
corpos novas formas de gestão de
empresas estão olhando que é chamado
sistema b empresas estão olhando muito
mais a parte humana muito mais a parte
dos colaboradores não só isso mas
descarte de produtos como é que é um
meio onde vive meio ambiente
sustentabilidade de forma real isso
passa inclusive valor em bolsa
valores e tal de rever o comportamento a
cultura da empresa internamente não dá
mais para esconder aquela aquele chefe
que assedia não dava pra fazer isso cara
isso mais do que é a parte bonitinha
comportamento também é valor
bolt também não adianta uma empresa uma
idéia o empreendimento só ser passivo
tem que ter ação agora levantar
bandeiras é extremamente necessário
ficou escondido ali mesmo em uma centena
bandeiras reais valores reais daquela
empresa e o último e pra mim o mais
importante b que aí e leva o brasileiro
no nível de diferenciação absurdo em
qualquer canto do mundo é esse o
borogodó
para godoy é só o que a gente tem
entendeu nenhum lugar do mundo pode ter
isso
o gol deu um jeitinho e tal não o da
malandragem não o dodô é o desnecessário
e aquela coisa errada nós brogodó na
nossa capacidade é cara como é que a
gente quebra essa barreira como é que a
gente pula isso como é que a gente é
criativo suficiente para achar uma nova
saída e aqui
de fato a gente tem uma uma vantagem
absurda promundo quarto valor
compartilhado mudança sem thierry com
alguma coisa não necessariamente
dinheiro
cara como é que a gente pode trazer pra
outros também outros virem pra nossa por
nosso lado pra ajudar isso seja de
informação seja de conexão seja de
possibilidades compartilhar mudança é um
bem extremamente necessário um exemplo
disso é que a gente pegou agora uma
outra empresa a gente pegou um espaço de
inovação entre o edital numa gigantesca
empresa nacional e pegou um espaço de
inovação é lindo e maravilhoso mas ainda
estéreo que a gente precisava fazer
levar gente para lá sem dinheiro sem
recurso que a gente vai fazer
vamos chamar com quem a gente se
relaciona vamos chamar a quem a gente
comporta vão botar olhos pra cá
compartilhando abundância que abundância
pra gente nesse momento conhecimento
então ainda bem a gente tem a sorte de
conhecer muitas pessoas muito legais
assim estavam 60 palestrantes para fazer
de graça um evento para 800 pessoas e
foi feito em
há uma semana uma semana pouco e botou
ali dentro da instituição gente pra
caramba cara botou gente ele nem sabia
como fazer direito só vamos fazer vamos
tocar o sino tocar a gente botou gente
de games gente de música do youtube
botou a gente de arte
sei lá mboto gente fotografia e grandes
pessoas da fotografia amigos nossos
gente de outros países só têm a indicar
o presidente da cufa estava lá e foi de
graça é legal
muita gente que nunca teria a
possibilidade de entrar ali
cara eu os meus sócios por exemplo
fazendo como podia vamos embora vamos
tocando entendeu agora godoy funcionando
por exemplo aqui ea gente vê quando
compartilha isso essa questão dos três
sócios nessa empreitada na empreitada
aqui a felicidade que dá de fato de
dever cumprido de coisas que nunca
aconteceram vamos buscar um novo vamos
fazer legal ou beleza alex só que a
instituição não estava pronta para isso
a minha velocidade é uma que eu acho que
é bacana mas a velocidade da instituição
por mais que deseje por mais que queira
o processo de mudança não está ainda no
ritmo
eu vou fazer o que eu vou botar pra
frente não vai dar certo e foi o que
aconteceu né
se não botar pra frente eu não respeitei
o quinto valor que o respeito do outro
lhe nem necessariamente pelo outro
se o cara me respeitam e me respeitam as
minhas características eu exijo que ele
que ele me respeite e eu tenho que
respeitar o cara naquele momento na
minha evolução na minha correria e não
estava respeitando ele nisso aqui
obviamente acontece em atritos acontece
o medo da mudança até do meu lado também
num caso desse
o que a gente fez a gente tem uma equipe
com cada uma característica extremamente
importante a liderança de um o coração
do outro a criatividade do outro a
felicidade enfim a irreverência de um
agente tava faltando um ponto ali e o
ponto veio inclusive no momento que eu
lembrei desse toque quando a gente
estava criando daquele vídeo é tem salas
de evento tem uma série de coisas que a
gente falou o seguinte a gente precisa
alguém pra apresentar e para receber as
pessoas e se alguém que a gente
contratou é o fábio fábio cadeirante
o fábio é deficiente visual e ele
apresenta no eficiente agente que
apresentava o seguinte naquele momento
só tem tem um equipamento assim tem isso
tem aquilo o fábio apresenta com o
coração era da mesma forma que aquela
pessoa que me mostrou que consegue ver
beleza com o dedo
o fábio está ali mostrando beleza
mostrando o que tem de alma que a gente
quer colocar antes do fábio entrar eu
cheguei pra pessoa que estava ali uma
das pessoas que estavam ali com uma
certa resistência e falei pra ele
cada agente vai contratar um
recepcionista agente vai contratar é uma
pessoa pra atender o pessoal aqui está
uma beleza e talento aqui mas tem um
detalhe ele é cadeirante e ele é
deficiente visual
aquela pessoa lê que inicialmente era o
meu principal e a principal barreira
passou naquele momento sem eu saber se o
nosso principal defensor
ele tinha uma filha com deficiência
visual alta de deficiência física ele
começa a desabar na minha frente de
choro e não têm ferramentas de gestão
nenhuma que possa me controlar no
momento desse
são dois eles respeitam de uma outra
forma é a gente tem um poder entre aspas
de deter uma instituição daquela como é
que a gente não tem vai ter o poder da
mente mudar situações como essa
e aí eu falo tem muita coisa que a gente
não sabe e está aberto ao novo é ser
vulnerável dessa parte então o
empreendedorismo é a gente vai tomar
porrada sim mas saber que a minha mãe a
gente ganha esse é o anti frágil e essa
malemolência e esse borogodó que eu acho
que a gente tem que ter em qualquer
parte mas ainda é a partir de olhar o
outro e saber que tem o valor do outro
ali pode ser valor muito pra quem está
do outro lado e entender é também uma
ferramenta absurda ou empatia é uma
ferramenta absurda de empreendedorismo
se a gente não tiver olhando pra isso a
gente vai estar olhando para uma coisa
só que o dinheiro empreendedorismo é
dinheiro sim mas não é só dinheiro
o dinheiro pode ser uma consequência
interessante do fato de você empreender
mas não é só pra isso que a gente está
no jogo não é só pra isso que a gente
está brincando e fica aqui a pergunta
esses são os meus cinco valores eu sei
que eu compartilho ele
os sócios com a minha equipe com todo
mundo que está envolvido nos projetos
sabendo ou não é isso que brilha nosso
olho é isso que faz a gente acordar de
manhã e para quem quer empreender para
quem empreende fica a pergunta quais são
seus valores é legal ver no ted a
quitexe desculpa que eu consigo ver que
o pessoal da organização por exemplo tem
sangue no olho pra fazer isso acontecer
quero com pouquíssimo recurso olha que
absurdo é ou a questão de compartilhar
mudança o conteúdo que a gente está
absorvendo e compartilhando aqui também
busca pelo novo novamente o conteúdo em
si é o esquecer o outro
ao compartilhar sangue no olho propósito
no coração é esse é talvez o principal
que é isso fazer porque acredita em um
momento desse respeito do outro respeito
vocês absurdamente vou respeitar o meu
medo de estar aqui pô é por fazer com
que isso que tem acontecido e fico
extremamente feliz de já ter passado 18
minutos e não ter desmaiado aqui no
palco valeu galera muito obrigado